foreign
does he have what kind of a stupid
question is that and why is a doctor in
a hospital asking it we know Fury had
his clearance revoked but you know Nick
Fury is the public figure who led the
Avengers and saved the world multiple
times and he quite literally brought you
the president of the United States why
the are you asking about clearance
and how would you know what I'm at my
limit for questions just take the three
sins and we'll move on
feel awkward later when Nigel gets
wheeled in for his routine colonoscopy
how do you get off that sub so easily
you'd think almost starting World War
III would at least get you held after
class how come we never see graphic in
his normal form when he's a new scrollos
I thought his whole selling point of the
camp is everyone gets to wear their
natural skin doesn't your leader
refusing to do the same kind of defeat
that selling point but what we know is
our war is yet to be set in motion
didn't you just say in the last episode
that you were starting your War does the
war automatically get negated if you
fail to kill your target were there
conditions to the war actually beginning
are your rules for war based on Calvin
ball
wow secret Invasion clearly graduated
from the Godzilla King of the monster
school for hiding special effects in the
dark glad to see kova didn't get the
school shut down I know it was hard on
enrollments shouldn't he have some blood
on his hand here or does shape-shifting
make it all go away or get absorbed
inside of him the former's too
convenient and the latter is ew show him
satellite footage of new scrawlers do
you think that maybe this is a
conversation you should be having in a
private space you're still out in the
open and I'm pretty sure one of your
soldiers just gave you I'm gonna stage a
Revolt eyes no this is leverage rather
no this is secret Invasion Leverage is a
much better series one that actually has
more than six episodes in a season so
you can have neat things like character
development and narrative arcs where's
the president
damn people's just giving out classified
information asking a question getting an
answer and then insulting the person who
gave it to you also why wasn't this guy
sent home that tells you a lot that even
Secret Service agents can't get a sick
day even when they're having issues with
both the secret and the service oh I
guess he could still block a bullet the
footage of you killing Maria Hill is
gonna get off every news program all
across the hemisphere how do you know
that though I can see you timing the
data to be sent to journalists but once
they have the video most news outlets
will want some time to analyze and vet
the footage contact experts and so forth
and they'll all do that at different
rates of speed depending on the
resources so you can't really know the
lead off simultaneously all that to say
your threat is dumb roads it would have
been easier just to say the video will
be sent to every news Outlet in 60
Seconds
now all of a sudden there's an
appropriate amount of agents at the
hospital they really could have sent
that injured guy home consider this a
preview Nick but why are you letting him
go I know you can't kill him because he
knows where the Harvest is and blah blah
blah but why not capture him and hold
him for interrogation letting him go
makes no strategic sense whatsoever
other than the fact that you still have
an episode left in the series politely
asking the location of Dr Rosa Dalton
thinking that just because you have a
chipper British accent you can point a
gun at someone and it's still somehow
polite hey look at that you shot him and
he changed back into his green skin
somebody should tell Nick this so he can
prove Roadie is a scroll I've tried but
I'm starting to think he doesn't
actually watch this channel what are you
confused about why some Scrolls have
human accents even when they're among
their own kind and no longer need
accents to blend in oh you were asking
Pato never mind carry on why the
are you punching him did none of you
grab a gun were you just hoping that a
mild beat down would be enough to get
this man planning mass murder to
surrender this Rebellion is dumb also
why did they waste time putting him on a
table or tables his crib tonight
come on man graphic isn't John Cena
there's no way that fireman's carries
got you out for the count
I know I'm supposed to be focused on
chadfick but I can't stop trying to
figure out how that door works behind
him is it supposed to be a swinging door
the doors don't move one inch when Beto
gets thrown through them but they swing
open and shut afterward set designer
needs to learn how to door and yes I did
just use doors of herb if you'd like to
file a complaint you can mail it to our
TV since office at 1060 West Addison
Street Chicago Illinois 60613 he died
on a foreign planet on a foreign ride
not to be confused with dying on a
foreigner Road I hear bodies that drop
there are cold as ice Taylor's told me
how you survived your execution yeah she
used the classic survival tactic a
montage calib City and Flora Colossus
I'll stop being pretentious just say
Groot he still Groot DNA we all know
what a Groot is
I'll be in touch how do you know these
police lights and Sirens are for you
could it just be a routine traffic
ticket if the government was coming for
you don't you think they'd send agents
to quietly approach like they did for
Bucky's arrest in Civil War don't worry
about me I'll put on a good face Fury
doesn't grown here but he wanted to so
I'll grown twice as loud for him
you don't need to show him slip away
from the police it's way less cool you
wouldn't show Batman slip away from
Commissioner Gordon would you who are
you who Who
I Really gotta know my name's Victor
that's was the one with his silencer
pressed against the base of your skull
okay this is low in dollar times but
Olivia Coleman is nothing less than a
delight fine take us an offer my
favorite British person in the MCU sorry
Peggy dude even with an accelerant that
building went up quick it must be made
out of that same wood at the church that
Ellie fought that pervert minister in
and Last of Us the males in my species
are very similar if they're not busy
gaslighting you they're threatening you
with murder
that's what all the podcasts are about
not reacting at all to someone magicing
a gun and drawing on you I like to think
he was too busy thinking of his favorite
episode of my favorite murder also I
know Fury is the main character here but
I'll be damned if Sonia isn't the one
actually being a super cagey lethal
super spy Olivia Coleman is great but I
wanted this from Samuel L too how
exactly did you get talos's body back
from the Secret Service did they just
leave him there beside the road I feel
like that's a pretty big detail for the
show to gloss over are you feeling Mr
President
helpless you may be feeling helpless but
considering the doctor said I'll crack
his chest you take the left me I'd say
you look pretty good for a man who just
had his chest cracked in a laparotomy
what you see on the screen is the scroll
compound you just walked into the room
with that tablet how the did you
get it hooked up on that television so
quickly it takes me three flips in a
handstand just to get my Chromecast to
work with my phone strike on Russian
soil
that means World War III I would rather
us face a war than Extinction oh and
what's nuclear winter a walk in the park
I'd like this joke more if I could
literally walk in a park right now
without melting I thought you were step
ahead of me no you told him he'd like to
think that Fury never said he actually
was how did the show manage to turn
Kingsley benedir into a terrible villain
I feel a lot better if we were on the
helical yeah that's been multiple that's
a funny way of saying the special
effects team was rushed and under
budgeted and yet you decided
the thing is
is I love this house oh cool they had
Darwin Awards on scrollos too when it
comes to facing down my executioners I'd
rather meet the bastard standing right
here in my happiness
than to meet them running down some dark
alley but no one cares about getting
blood stains out of Alleyways that's
what they're there for also sure was
cool with the Assassins to wait until
the most dramatic time invara's
conversation before taking their first
shot stealing the backpack body Shield
Mr Nobody used in John Wick chapter four
these top words translate to Red notice
and finish that's a Ryan Reynolds movie
and Ryan Reynolds is Deadpool oh it's an
Easter egg did I Solve the Riddle tell
me what I've won
man keep the wig maybe you'll need it
again how much does it even weigh It's A
Wig and yes I pick up everything in RPGs
and no I never use any of my potions
just on the off chance I may need them
you're right I am very good at video
games
[Music]
having the audacity to question Sonia's
taste in hip-hop what I have known by
looking at these trees if Nick Fury was
instead 293 kilometers from the Russian
border or 295 kilometers from the
Russian border of course not now if
they'd specified this was 183 miles from
the Russian border I'd have known my
brain only reads Freedom Units Marvel
last I checked Roadie is a scroll
what and you said I'd lost my touch well
you haven't lost your touch from
pointlessly keeping secrets from your
allies in the aftermath some were sent
in to collect that DNA that's a cool
Theory but in practice how would you
tell Carol Danvers Blood on the ground
from any other Avengers blood isn't it
all mostly red wouldn't you need to
already have some of her DNA to compare
it to and no gravity got the right
sample none of this tracks how do you
think I came back this sin isn't fair
unlike all the other ones here which are
totally super legit and completely
objective but don't you just hate it
when you open a door too far and then it
rebounds and tries to close itself again
which is exactly what happens to Fury
here I hate it they really should have
reshot this entire scene
where did that hat come from Samuel L is
this a continuity error or even worse
did your character put on a hat off
screen
come to think of it this episode has
been completely bereft of hat changes
Gary why haven't you called any of your
special friends Dan this is personal
we can't keep depending on these
superheroes to swoop in and save our
asses don't you decide that for me for
the record if any superheroes are
watching this feel free to save the
out of me this is personal well that's a
funny way of saying we can't afford them
they do say Darwin never sleeps
let's give our Extinction a nice leg up
I already made a Darwin joke and I'm not
changing it now just because she made a
Darwin joke it's her fault you're
getting two Darwin jokes blame her there
it is I'm sure his contract requires at
least one hat switch in episode even if
it's switching from one knit hat to
another knit hat Samuel L has got to get
his fix
I'm taking a sin away because this pose
is the coolest thing he's done in this
entire series and then I'm adding Us in
back because this pose is the coolest
thing he's done in this entire series
and yes I know he shot down a helicopter
but helicopters ain't let's finish this
yes please kind of bored out of my
scroll
a new paper boy done gone and broke my
sternum get over here Pagan thought he
had a voice
but none of you do
this isn't a democracy anymore tell
graphic I'm coming for him and hell's
coming with me you here who are you I
think a more apt question would be who
would you like me to be that could be
fun if you want offensive smart
superstitious Brave and uh if you let
him see I could be whatever you want you
just tell me what you want and I'll be
there for you it's okay
I know it